[Music]  what if the stories you remember  changed in a way you'd never forget  t'challa  what if the heroes you knew  became something larger than life  on august 11th  expect  the unexpected  that's weird and ask yourself the  question  what if  streaming august 11th only on disney  plus  yeah peace i love peace i'd be out of a  job with peace  do we know each other  time  reality reality  it's changeable  where you want to be  that's the question didn't it  every universe  is different  each one  you need  slow down a little bit there's a few  people in the room that don't understand  not me i get it  who are you  the name's captain carter  [Music]  i am the watcher  i observe all that transpires here  but i do not cannot will not interfere  i guess i have to freestyle then  i said never flies  solo  is that some kind of catchphrase  you had me wear it for a second  journey to face the unknown  and ponder the question  what if  [Music]  you